اهلا بكم في هذه النافذه الانسانيه الخاصه
وفيها نناقش استمرار قوات الاحتلال
باستهداف الصحفيين في قطاع غزه عقب
استشهاد الصحفيين مصطفى ثريا وحمزه نجل
الزميل وائل الدحدوح في قصف اسرائيلي
استهدف مجموعه من الصحفيين شمال
رفح شبكه الجزيره قالت ان اغتيال الزميلين
مصطفى وحمزه يؤكد من جديد
على ضروره اتخاذ جميع الاجراءات القانونيه
الفوريه واللازمه بحق قوات الاحتلال لضمان
عدم الافلات من العقاب لمناقشه هذا الملف
سيكون معنا من باريس جيل ديفير استاذ
القانون الدولي والمحامي المعتمد لدى
المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه اذا باستشهاد
الصحفيين مصطفى ثريا وحمزه وائل الدحدوح
يرتفع عدد الصحفيين الذين الذين استشهدوا
او استشهدوا في غزه جراء الاستهداف والقصف
الاسرائيلي الى
109 والان ينضم الينا من باريس جل ديفير
استاذ القانون الدولي والمحامي المعتمد
لدى المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه اهلا بك سيد
ديفير لماذا يعجز القانون الدولي عن حمايه
الصحفيين في
غزه
القانون الدولي يجد صعوبه للصعوبات لاننا
نتعامل
مع مجرمين ومجرمين منظمين اذا القانون
يمكن ان
يشخص الجريمه وقتل هذه هذا العدد الكبير
من
الصحفيين يمثل جريمه السؤال هو سؤال
الاجراءات الشيء الوحيد الذي تغير انه بعد
جهود لسنوات عديده نحن قريبون من الاجراء
الاول ضد القوه الاسرائيليه المحتله
وسيكون هناك
محاكمه في الحادي عشر والثاني عشر من هذا
الشهر في المحكمه العدل الدوليه وهذه
بدايه جيده بدايه عمليه واجراء
جديد كيف تتوقعون ان تكون نتيجه جديده
هناك محاولات عديده تمت في السابق لم
تترجم الى محاسبه حقيقيه لاسرائيل كيف
سيختلف الامر هذه
المره ما هو
مختلف هو اننا
وضعنا الملف
فيلف
المناسب
وهو المحكمه العدل
الدوليه ب من بمبادره
من جنوب افريقيا وكذلك المحكمه الجنائيه
الدوليه بشكوى فلسطينيه الاجراءات الى حد
الان لم يكن لها اثر لان المدعي العام
تاخر ولكن القضيتين معا جعل انه في الجانب
المدني في الحادي عشر والثاني عش هناك طلب
لاتخاذ اجراءات عاجله
لحمايه الفلسطينيين وجميع الملاحظين
ينتظرون قرارا يكون ايجابيا قبل نهايه شهر
يناير نتحدث عن الصحفيين
تحديدا هل هناك اجراء
احترازي يمكن ان يردع اس عن استهدافهم
بهذه الصوره المباشره كما
يبدو جنوب
افريقيا وضحت هذا واولا ايقاف القصف
وحمايه المدنيين وهذا اول طلب تقدمت به
جنوب افريقيا ونحن نتابع ذلك باهتمام كبير
تتابعوا رد المحكمه لان في هذه الشكوى
امام المحكمه الجنائيه هناك عناصر واضحه
تتعلق بالصحفيين كل يوم كل يوم
هناك صحفي يقتل لم نشهد هذا من قبل لذ نحن
نلح على المؤسسات لكي
تحميهم نعم ولكن القانون الدولي هو ما
نسال عنه وانت خبير في
وبالنسبه للماده الرابعه في اتفاقيه جنيف
الثالثه او الماده ال9 من البروتوكول
الاضافي هل يتضمنان ما يكفي من اجل توفير
الحمايه
والمحاسبه لمن يستهين بهذه
الحقوق
ينبغي ان نكون
دقيقين هذه طبعا ذكرى
الصحفيين هناك
قدرتنا بفضل شجاعتهم لكي يكون لنا عناصر
وبراهين القانونان او مواد القانون واضحه
وصريحه وتقول ان حمايه الصحفيين بشكل خاص
اذا اذا
اراد ان يعمل هو لا يريدنا ان نعرف هذا ما
يجري القانون كافن القانون الدولي جيد ما
كان ينقص هو توازن القوى
لاجبار القضاء على ان يصدر احكامه ولكي
يكون
هناك اجراءات لايقاف المجرمين وبعد
الاجراءات حول الاجراءات العاجله
سيكون
هناك تقديم طلبات واتخاذ اجراءات اذا هي
ليست قضيه واحده هي مجموعه قضايا وينبغي
الوصول الى ان السيد نتنياهو كرئيس وزراء
نعم يساءل عن هذه الجرائم وانا اتابع
تصريحاته كل يوم منذ البدايه لم يكن هناك
اي كلمه الندم عن الصحفيين الذين قتلوا
والذين هم يعتبرون مدنيين
ومن الاوامر التي اصدرها هي قتل الجميع
اذا ادانته
واضحه ومسؤوليته واضحه وبفضل الجهود
المبذوله نحن الان سوف نكون امام المدعي
العام على العموم ايام فقط تفصلنا عن هذه
المواجهه القانونيه وسنتابع فعلا اذا كانت
تحمل جديدا هذه المره اشكرك من باريس للدب
استاذ القانون الدولي والمحامي المعتمد
لدى المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه واشكركم
مشاهدينا نعود بكم الى استوديو الاخبار
والتغطيه في مه